just before we get started can I check
everyone to go up the addendum saying it
okay still got a couple of minutes out
just before we start I'll read the
emergency evacuation announcements
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the nearest available exit
to the chamber or assembly point on
being the public car park at the side of
the Civic suite please don't delay your
evacuation by collecting belongings
please don't return into the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that the
meeting won't be audio recorded and if
you have a phone please put it on silent
thank you
so welcome to the Development Committee
24th of January 2019 apologies for
absence councillor mrs. Shaw councillor
mr. Shaw and in terms of substitution
counts the mrs. Shaw substituted by
counsel Lucas kale counts the mr. Shaw
by councillor FD non-members attending
we have counselor mr. Huy minutes of the
meeting held on the 9th of January 2019
will you be happy for me to sign those
as a correct and accurate record of that
meeting not at this point mrs. Howe I
[Music]
was
he was misinformed because the
Constitution cited States that I could
have spoke on the David Wilson homes
application so I'd like an apology you
know dude please yes about that at the
end of the meeting I as you're fully
aware I I made in a spec based on the
advice that officers gave so you were
asked to leave the meeting earlier than
you should have been on that occasion
that's been noted and shan't happen
again in future thank you sorry about
that out of five declarations of
interests that on everyone's behalf as
members on note or interest in the South
Street application are there any others
thank you very much all right that takes
us on to item six for which we have the
the small addendum mr. Evans going to do
this one Thank You chairman good evening
members the application before us is an
application to very condition two of the
full Planning Commission issued on the
20th of July 2018 in respect to 14
dwellings proposed alongside associated
landscaping parking and other associated
works that scheme comprised in total
seven number of two-bedroom houses five
a number of three-bedroom houses one
five bedroom house and a one six bedroom
house the only matter that the council
can and has to take into account is
whether it is considered the revisions
to be acceptable will gone to the first
slide so currently the see very well
here myself the site is here it's this
rectangular site here located off uncle
lane and it's currently under
construction for the granting of the
permission it's a linear cyclic AIDS the
Northmen killeen and east of that
residential development known as C the
walk and south of residential properties
located at Ashe green which the
properties located here see the walking
here
and then this will probably remember
that there's there is developments
currently in place here that the
adjacent sites are the west which makes
up the total allocation for that path of
kanuda n-- i just like to point out as
well that i will show a couple of
photographs in the presentation that's
what i would say is that in terms of the
site itself there is a differential in
land levels between the actual site
itself which is relatively sloping off
to south and the rear curtilage --is of
Ash green here there's a differential of
approximately 2.7 meters in difference
as I've observed developments taking
place on site so I would say that from
what I can observe during this
construction period is that the land
levels of the finished floor levels of
properties will be approximately 2.5 to
2.7 below the land levels of the
curtilage is arash green I just thought
I'd mention that members will miracle
had access to the - of the frontage
properties if we can go on to perhaps
perhaps yes just assure this the there
are two frontage properties within the
development that are served directly
from an Colleen with the remaining
access coming from the site that is
under development now so we'll just stay
on that slide so yes that the frontage
properties gained director Frank Elaine
very shared surface access the
application seeks to amend specific
aspects of the sister of this
substantive scheme which in terms is
quantum and overall effect is is
considered to have no significant
impacts which it was consider however
that the application was best addressed
or the revisions were best addressed
through the section 73 route of the
tunnel Country Planning Act rather than
as non-material amendments because there
are some material changes that third
parties do may have comments regarding
which as it has actually turned out to
be the case as members not from
a report where there are two
representations received from number 11
and there's a sadness green and also in
the addendum item there's a further
correspondence recorded there so in
terms of the slide that I'm showing in a
slide to the approved site layout then
shows the affordable housing aspect of
the scheme two and three-bedroom
terraced properties at the north of the
site here bordering with ash green
you've got some terrorist properties
here plot five to nine you've got plot
three to four here and then you've got
the large properties the five and the
six bedroom properties to the front just
to give an idea of these just remind you
of the layout so the yes so the actually
approved site layer plan which is now
proposed to slightly mentions the rear
garden space serving those affordable
toon three-bedroom properties look it's
the North portion so members may note
also that in this area here and written
in into the original permission the
there is an eco strip that is supposed
to be maintained the rear of these
properties as there are badges there is
badge activity in this area here and
down the west flank of the site that's
the general layout parking four plots
three and four
there was an under Croft in this area
here that provided access to the rear of
plot three and four so we'll go through
the changes in detail now so if we can
go on to and basically just to indicate
also that's the the affordable housing
element is actually going to be taken
forward by the shellner housing group
which of these properties here which is
the affordable housing elements so in
terms of the the layouts as now proposed
the only difference as Sean as indicated
on the on the plan is now it's proposed
to actually construct a not point five
meter wide path along a strip along the
rear
and along the east flank of the site
just to provide access for numbers 11 to
14 so they can get access to the rear of
their site that was something that was
actually set out as a requirement under
the design quality requirements of the
obvious the housing association yes so
the actual path itself what's important
to North is is that the path is actually
going to be located three metres from
the boundary of the site so it's
important that this eco strip is
maintained for badger movement the
original designer max a statement that
accompanied this application the
original application set out the the
provisions for badgers so I think one of
the concerns was with this eco strip and
in terms of the effect of the built form
and and and also the rear garden
boundaries of the properties here was in
terms of badger movements from this area
to to feed and also to gain access to
water and I'll just refer to this issue
because it is relevant in terms of where
this path is in relation to the Eco
strip and it says on the ecological
mitigation documents that has been
conditioned as part of the substantive
consent that the location of badger set
a talk was 2018 walk over the two meter
wide ecology strip for badger movements
with a 30 centimeter by 30 centimeter
fence opening at western and eastern end
so I think in accordance with looking at
the acceptability over this path we do
have to consider as to whether that
would have had any impact upon badger
movements and on the provision of the
Eco strip and I'd like perhaps to I will
show you a picture just in a short while
which actually indicates where that Eco
strip is in in real terms now in terms
of I will at this point also refer to
the objections received from from third
parties
now the objection received cited
concerns regarding the use of the path
just to clarify them that the use of the
path will be by those residents
occupying number 11 to 14 whilst number
10 does have access of its own along the
eastern flank of the site so it does not
need this rear access via this path so
what what the agent has confirmed is
that at this point here there will be a
gate with a corded entry on it so it'll
be it'll restrict access to the users to
the residents of those properties only
which was a concern the other concern
was actually was when people perhaps
were using this path to gain access to
their property that they would be able
to see directly into the garden areas of
those properties are ash green I visited
number 7 ash green during my assessments
of the application just again an
appreciation of the differential between
the the the application site and those
properties
now what this photograph actually shows
I know it's sort of close up but this is
the fencing that is actually protecting
the badger strip this eco strip
currently from the development and
basically from the base of where this
fences to the top of the fence which
bans the southern boundary of ash green
there's there's approximately a two
point seven meter differential and the
the reason I'm showing you this picture
members is that if a person was walking
along here what I've worked out a
six-foot person their head would be
level at the top of this fence taking
that the level of the path is roughly
going to be level with the current level
of the bottom of the fence so that is
how that we've come to the conclusion
that the use of that path by a minimum
number of people would not actually
result in over looking into those garden
areas on the basis of that height
differential
and we're going to slide 4 so I'm just
going to show this is the the second
aspect of the change which is the
changes to plots 5 to 9 so plots 5 to 9
are located along the east and aspect of
the site so basically plots 5 to 9 these
are the elevation drawings terrace type
properties thor's that's the rear
elevation plan two and three-bedroom
houses so the rear elevation
incorporates a classic French door wings
with no sort of canopies or anything and
then we go on to what is now proposed
which is a slight revision to the rear
elevation and that's the that's the
color photograph of of the existing
approved plan and then we'll go on to
the next slide please and that should
show the minor revision so what members
will see then to the rear elevation the
side profile drawing depicts what's
proposed so in order to write a little
bit more room to the living space a
lean-to projection is proposed to along
the rear of these properties here which
is a roughly at 1.72 projection just to
kick out the rear elevation at first
floor at ground floor level only so the
there is a slight change also to the the
size of the apertures of the French door
kind openings so it's just basically
providing a little bit more additional
ground floor space for these properties
so that is the second revision which is
B in the reports and there we go -
elevation 3 yes so these are plots 3 and
4 and what was proposed here's an
arrangement was this is the south aspect
of plot 3 and 4 and basically the pack
was short was shown to the rear garden
areas of plot 3 and 4 but with an under
Croft
as part of the design to provide access
to the parking area
now that's arrangement has been amended
which is shown by the next slide which
is to basically there's there's an
infill of this undercroft area so the
gap which cars would would have come
through on the previous plan that will
be filled in to provide language
accommodation and we'll go on then to
look at well where how this parking is
mitigated where is it actually provided
as an alternative so we'll move on to
the AIT's alternative parking
arrangements and that's yeah yeah so on
the on the original approved plan this
area constitutes an area of a sliver of
greenery here lawn area so because this
area has been closed up to provide the
rear garden with additional living space
the parking provision for plot 3 which
is this plot he has been provided in
this area here and the provision of
parking for plot 4 has been provided in
this area here these parking spaces are
standard parking spaces of 2.9 I think
they're over the guidance by 5.2 in
length so what actually it's resulted in
through the through the slight amendment
is there's a net gain of one parking
space making a total of 37 parking
spaces within the site in total as
opposed to the previous 36 and really
basically that leads me to the the
addendum item which is which wasn't
reported previously which is the canoed
and parish council had no comments to
make no adverse comments and there was a
representation received from the
occupier and i'd like to make a
correction which was 20 see the walkin
udûn which was the concern regarding how
the path was going to be protected from
the adjacent houses at the side and that
has been sort of partly answered in the
fact that it'll be a a controlled gated
access to a minimum number of people so
the eco strip is
which is an important aspect of the
scheme and just coming fall to the
recommendation members will note that
the conditions of the original
substantive consents have been
reiterated in full which is what got
government guidance recommends and
therefore it is the recommendations Emin
that subjects who been bound and written
into into the obligation of the legal
agreement dated 22 july that a new
consent is issued but carrying all the
safeguards that were sourced by the
original permission thank you we've had
quite a detailed explanation there of
the changes the recommendations of
posted through from six point one
through two six point seven counts the
step tail Thank You chairman I'm sorry
sorry oh sorry I mean I missed you count
slowly first yep Thank You chairman I
wasn't planning to speak but I can't
resist picking up anything on parking as
you may well know so it's two point nine
by five point five is our minimum is the
standard and I thought yes it is parking
standard suggested where you have
end-on-end parking that the spaces
should be longer than that that is just
the point I wanted to raise and if I
could have confirmation I'm correcting
that would be grateful or incorrect if
your may we we've had these these spaces
are measured at five point nine in
length so they are in excess of that so
just one confirmation I heard two point
nine by 5.2 if I've misheard that that's
fine thinking we'll just restate that to
you in May right but that counts the
Steptoe thank you can we have two
picture backup of where the footpath and
the the Badger bit is pleasant
but were the one with all the bushes
that's it I'm unclear from the
photograph which is the back of the
existing properties and which is the
back of the new properties first of all
with looking at the photograph which
side is the back of the existing
properties and which is the back of the
new properties so which way round is it
orientated
so that's what you also that photograph
there is the east boundary of the site
so we've come back from ourselves from
other sports go back to here so the rear
boundary of the Ashwini's is here
basically so I would say from where that
fence is there's about three and a half
meters and distance between the bottom
of the fencing where the stake is to
whether
fancies
so on that basis anybody using the
footpath won't be able to see into the
existing properties gardens but the
existing properties could be overlooked
in the new properties I'm correct in
saying because they're higher okay the
other question I had was with around the
badges themselves obviously we're going
to encourage badges to use this banking
which looks quite a nice place for for a
nice badger set will that cause problems
with the existing properties at the top
of the slope with badgers tunneling
their way through and I've been to the
gardens there is there any way of
mitigating that stop that I don't think
we've been asked to consider the
potential activities of tunneling
creatures as a planning consideration
but go on the one incidence in terms of
furthest the granting off permission
there was a the planning permission
specifies that certain works had to be
done in terms of one direction of the
fence to safeguard the Badgers from
encroachment other developments the
council was contacted by the Essex
Wildlife Trust which had concerns
because concerns have been raised by
residents and what is clear is is that
in terms of our regulatory remit as a
planning authority in terms of what we
can do we realize that developments will
perhaps encourage badges to look further
other sort of sights but it's good this
is historical so we basically I wrote to
the agent email the agents and asked him
to clarify as to whether the on-site
ecological measures have been undertaken
in accordance with the conditions and
the actual ecologist contact me kanta
means himself and said that in terms of
how the permission is being implemented
and with regards to safeguarding Badgers
that it was in accordance with the
ecological mitigation plan but however
that I don't think the planning can
stretch as far as to
to preempt what may happen next in terms
of how badges will possibly progress
further north and the issues that are
raised with with the peopling in
people's gardens that that's a difficult
issue but I'm satisfied the Wiis and
authority of done all we can
under the our regulatory remit in that
respect I don't want to get distracted
by budgets in terms of determining the
application properly all I was going to
suggest was perhaps the the group that
looks after the badges welfare perhaps
if any slightly informative that they
work with the developer to make sure
that there isn't any further develop
issues at a later date you know take the
other speakers first it was sorry
Thank You chairman just wanted to ask in
relation to the the footpath that's been
added in in relation to bin storage
these have been storage for those
properties at the front of the
properties or are is it intended that
this footpath is to be used for the bins
to be brought round from the rear of the
properties and another question in sorry
chairman this is a badger question the
the Eko corridor that he's proposed is
is that a historic badger run because
anyone who's had me dealing with badgers
knows that they're they tend to use
particular runs aims they're quite
determined that you know if they've got
a specific run doesn't matter what's put
in their way they will borrow destroy
make their way I'm hearing what you're
saying but listening to the officer
they're the appropriate authority has
given their
blessing for want of a better word that
things have been done properly and in
accordance with the standards that we've
set ourselves and I think it is
difficult for us to challenge that that
premise yeah this seems to be a little
bit of a question about Essex boy lost
trust who are an expert in this field as
to whether they're completely happy with
the situation just want to clarify that
really does anyone else want to ask any
questions before we so we've got the
Badger the parking some parking sighs
Thank You chairman just just to help
members members did correctly here 5.2
but that was a site era they have been
measured at two point nine by five point
nine which is the five point five sorry
now I've done it
two point nine by five point five which
is the correct standards so that that's
the case there in terms of in line the
members may have me at a disadvantage um
I'm only familiar with where parking
spaces are in front of garages the
highway authority normally is concerned
about that the kickback weather where
the door will open unless it's one of
those roller type ones where it kicks
out they require sometimes an extra
meter so that in order to open the
garage the car bumper if you like isn't
over the pavement where you see parking
on particularly visitor spaces like we
see on the modern schemes we're getting
with where the urban designers like them
provided if you like curbside in lay
buyers their members are right those
spaces are sometimes elongated so it's
better to get the vehicle to be able to
back in and turn in but the space is
that you've got for consideration
tonight are domestic spaces where there
isn't that flowing traffic going past
then it's quite an order for the 25.5 s
to be sat in to end
unless of course perhaps in front of
there at perhaps a garage in which case
another meter would have been preferable
but these spaces before you aren't in
front of garages the bins and my
understanding is is that that is is
precisely what the path is for but it
it's it's it's perhaps wider than that
but I - thing is that yes the bins will
be bought around that
half to the front on bin collection day
and it's also to provide access to
provide you know to bring gardening
tools etc to the rear because it they're
sort of locked by the fact that the
terrace properties and just the Eco
corridor wasn't it yeah just get it in
research you've previously heard from
the ecological mitigation plan that was
submitted with the original application
the the reports this by the by the
diversity method statement indicates
that it cited that the area the area in
question is this is where the highest
badger activity was but I don't recall
it's being said or stated anywhere that
you know where the precise runs were
however from from the report it does
actually indicate an annotate that what
I caught it before that the ecology
strip would be provided for badger
movement with a 30 centimeter by 30
cents of Defense opening at western and
eastern ends so that does suggest that
they do know where the badger run is and
the ecology strip is is coincides with
that badger run okay members I think
we've had a chance to explore this one
quite thoroughly so have a
recommendation for approval 6.1 through
26.7 those members in favor of the
approval please indicate thank you very
much that's unanimous
item seven she's council offices seven
South Street remembers the item eight
when we get to it we'll move through
that fairly quickly because the content
is essentially the same as item seven
yes really I would sort of basically
they're two reciprocal applications in
terms of what the works involved but
have to be treated slightly separately
due to the planning and the listed
building and conservation area statutes
so in in effect and this is a minor
mate'll alteration to agree to listed
building which is a red brick and red
plain tiled roof the proposed work will
effect the rear part of the building and
purely replacing a window that was added
after the original construction and
perhaps if you could just move to the
photograph please the I think most
members will recognize where that is now
my understanding is it's in some kind of
area where when money or anything of
values exchange in terms of the Sakura
core coming there and taking money away
from the accounts etc so basically the
proposal simply is to replace this
window with a steel security door that
is framed within a steel frame and the
the supporting statement just says is
that these changes are required in order
to make the council's business more
efficient and I think if members will
see that from the photograph that what
you have you have a hatch here hatched
area with security across this window
and I suspect that items of value is
placed within this area here and
obviously taken away I think there's a
need now to actually gain access for
safety into the building
and it's it's an operational requirement
by the council to comply with various
regulations but if we'd sure the the
next photograph and yeah if I don't know
we can if we can so that's it's just the
photograph of its head on so I think
what is indicative as well as members
will actually see from that plan what is
quite telling is is that there's a faint
line in the brickwork here we're
actually at some point in time this used
to be a larger opening in any case so
really what the proposal involves is to
put a door in here to replicate what was
previous what was the previous
arrangement the doors are sealed or
painted in in a in a white finish the
Essex play services commented that they
had no adverse comments regarding the -
thetic changes as it was described and
therefore in terms of the first
application which is under the the
Planning Act section 91 of a ton of
country Planning Act there's a
recommendation members that planning
permission be granted subject to the
provisions of the statutes as indicated
by condition 1 and also condition 2 and
3 which provides certainty in terms of
what's what is actually recommended as
going forward does anyone have anything
to say about this members the
recommendation for approval and printed
on 7.1 those members in favor of
changing a window to a door please
indicate we still need to do things the
proper way thank you that's unanimous so
item eight is the same but because the
building is listed this does need to be
taken as a separate item and we do need
to seek consent to allow us to do this
so very very quickly the report and the
point five point one water planning
statues tell us is where a listed
building is involved where you've got a
concurrent planning application the fact
that it's listed basically provides the
materials waiting is to be given for the
fact it's listed above all else and
therefore the only change of members
will not in the reporters there's a
slight tweak in the actual status that
referred to same developments are so the
only change really is in the
recommendation and the condition one
that refers to subsection 80 in section
one of the planning Lister buildings and
conservation zaire is act 1990 so
granted and separate and slightly
different statutes and therefore Slee
recommended for consent okay so it's the
recommendation on 8.1 as members in
favor of the approval please indicate
thank you
that's what replying for listed building
it sentence right our next item is the
referred item from the weekly list land
opposite rectory rectory farmhouse
fanbridge Road Ashington mr. Strang
Thank You chairman
you just bear with us a moment while we
catch up have you got the Bing image to
start with cheese clear thanks thanks
very much
this application chairman is on the
eastern side of fanbridge Road about 50
meters or so from our undal Road we see
here usefully the site is edged in red
as you will see it's open farm and
either side and it joins Essex plot land
and members we've not see any boundary
at all in red chairman the site I'll
follow the laser over it there you see
comes down in this part and then there's
a rectangular shaped site
it's about 63 meters in depth but 27
meters or so in width and it has an area
which is worth noting at the moment of
0.17 of a hectare members can see on
there it's mostly grass with occasional
hedge and trees but the boundaries are
strongly hedged both to the roadway as
well as to the land to the north and
south and east and if we could jump to
the block layout please the proposal
before you tonight is to largely keep
the site open and undeveloped but it
concerns this area here which is a
proposed stable for one horse and we see
the building in detail in a moment which
is to be located in this like northeast
corner the existing access is to be used
here which would be hard surface and
then a more loose material for this part
here highways of course prefer to have a
hard surface for the first six meters or
so so that the detritus doesn't get
collected in vehicles and then dropped
on the on the highway in the tires so
it's quite proper to have a a hard
surface entry into the site then perhaps
an alternative choice of material that's
shown here with the proposed stable
building in this corner if we could jump
to the elevations please the stable
building is of a traditional timber
structure and design you'll see that the
width of it is four point two meters and
a depth of nine point seven with a ridge
high overall ground to the main
Ridgeline a four point to the walling
typically that
two point six meters in height if we
could jump to the floorplan please
members will say that although it's sort
of a box as it were is indicative
divisions that provide the stable at
that end with its own door and then a
double door to give a a store and an
attack room if we can jump back to the
block layout the site chairman is in the
Greenbelt now the construction of new
buildings as members will recall is in
appropriate development in accordance
with national policy but it does allow
exceptions that are appropriate
facilities for outdoor recreation but
there's an important caveat to that and
that is as long as the facilities prefer
preserve openness in the Greenbelt now
one example is like sports pavilions
with changing rooms at football pitches
because you've got the facility of the
toilets and the changing rooms what you
have keeping the site open is the
football pitches the pavilion
necessitates the pitches the same is
here where you have a stable approved in
the Greenbelt yes you get development
where there was none but what it does in
turn it guarantees more or less the
remainder of the site to be kept open
now the responsibilities of the council
has is that there should be a degree of
openness with all development approved
in the Greenbelt now you'll have seen
many times in this committee that we've
recommended to you that you can approve
stable developments this is slightly
different because in order to guarantee
that extent of openness we've borrowed
the national horse society standards
which say that for a horse it does vary
depending on size and the health of the
horse some horses a laminate Akande
don't require grazing but in order that
you don't get small parcels of land
developed with stables builders that a
disproportionate in size to the actual
parcel we use the welfare guide of the
British horse society which argues for
around point four of a hectare one acre
of land per box this is a box for one
Shetland pony
and the actual hectare each only works
out at point one seven that is less than
half the amount that you would normally
require particularly for
average horse now as you're safe from
the report that officers have taken of
you that the site really isn't big
enough for the development as it were
proposed there may be a welfare issue as
well because sometimes when you you have
an animal on an undersized plot the site
becomes over grazed and a nun tempt it
becomes poached as I say where all the
hoof marks fill up with with water and
it also a bigger site would allow a more
managed grazing where some parts could
be rested and and others not but the
point is not so much about the animal
welfare in terms of the dispute that the
animal will be fed on on feedstuffs and
not require so much grazing the job of
the planning decision is to achieve a
spatial relationship between built form
and the extent of sites like I opened
with the pitches analogy in this case we
use the welfare argument to accept or
otherwise the amount of built form that
you're getting in relation to the
relatively small size of the plot so the
recommendation chairman you'll see from
the report is one of refusal for the
reasons set out there
Thank You chairman good evening members
the Planning Officers report confirms
that the proposal complies with all
relevant criteria of planning policy DM
15 with the exception of criterion free
this states that there should be one
stable pernot point four hectares of
site area which is comparable the
British horse Society standard we have
acknowledged that the site area falls
below this figure however this is only a
guide and can only ever be a guide as
numerous factors have to be taken into
account such as the size of the horse or
pony the length of time it's tabled the
time of year the quality of the pasture
the number of animals and how well with
the pasture is managed the applicant is
seeking to stable a Shetland pony on
site and we've been formed by a member
of the British Horse Council that the
size of the plot is more than adequate
the proposed stable will include a feed
embedding store as the ponies do not
require extensive grazing on the land
ask a pony owner and they will tell you
that ponies are tougher smarter stronger
and healthier than any horse
they tend to be Hardy er have few hoof
problems and are less prone to some
types of colic they also run on a lot
less fuel rations that would normally
starve a horse will keep a pony round
and energetic most Pony breeds developed
where the pasture was very sparsh
the terrain rugged and the climate harsh
and thus they had to work to find their
food and in short they evolved to use
what little food they could find very
efficiently when we pamper them when we
feed them special preparations and lush
grass we often do more harm than good
overfeeding is more of a problem for
ponies than under feeding so ponies only
need a fraction of the feed that horses
do and hay for ponies should be good
quality grass hay the pony won't need
the nutrition provided by alfalfa and
clovers these fodders which are more
energy and nutrition dense than the
grass hay often too rich for a pony the
applicant is fundamentally concerned
with the welfare of their ponies and the
need for a shelter on sight the plot
size is only for the ponies who wander
around in the most important thing is to
look after their welfare and to keep
fed watered dry and warm the adjoining
sight to the self obtained Planning
Commission for stables in 2001 and
currently two fully grown horses are
stabled there the land is unimaginable
and occasionally tonight
there have been known significant
planning policy amendments regarding the
green belt in that time and no changes
to the British horse society standards
so we question why the application site
in this instance is being treated
differently to the ones the south the
applicant is only application site for
approximately 30 years and as recent
experience problems with trespass in a
legal settlement they prefer to have
stable and their horse their pony on the
site and defer future trespassing
believes that the proposal would result
in the optimum use of the site for their
benefit the National Planning policy
framework is pro development the
proposal constitutes outdoor sport and
recreation facilities which is
appropriate development in the Greenbelt
and indeed stables are synonymous with
the countryside and the Greenbelt but
notice that the application is before
you tonight with the recommendation of
refusal however we've believed that an
approval can be granted subject to a
suite of reasonably worded conditions
and will be welcoming of any conditions
the committee deemed necessary it's
important to note there have been no
objection statutory consort ease
included the parish council or any third
parties members are respectfully
requested to grant plan permission
subject to conditions Thank You chairman
yeah councillor mister hi thank you
chairman and I think we all understand
that the point that mr. strengths made
around the point four hectares is really
a question of rent open space in
relation to the building however the
speaker did raise the point that it
would be a Shetland pony in there
however why just the question is I
assume it's not really possible to pour
conditioning that was just restricts the
occupation to a Shetland pony
I've seen planning conditions to people
before but never to apparently yes
actually it is worth commenting on that
I think this chairman if I may and the
speaker did refer to I don't if we could
jump to the location plan if that helps
the applicants one the speaker did refer
to the site to the south and we've had
chance given what they said to look at
that it's a bigger site
it's about point four of a hectare in
size and the officer report in 2001
talks to being below the standard at
that time they seem to relied on on
point five of a hectare now unlike the
speaker I'm not sure that the stand had
actually changed but it seems when they
dealt with this application which is in
this area here they were looking at what
they felt was a larger site which you
can see in comparison but they did to
pick up the point raised by members they
did condition the building to be used
for to Shetland ponies or one horse now
if the speaker is correct that there's
two larger horses in there they are in
breach of that consent but it had to
answer the point raised it is possible
to we've done it before on that site to
condition for two Shetland ponies but
you know it requires equal choirs
monitoring thank you that's the mrs.
Reston you referred this item yes thank
you chairman I think the speaker was
very well what he spoke on this yeah
obviously in your report you you do
speak about a horse and yes they are
talking about a Shetland pony and I was
going to say that if if we get to put
this as a approval tonight I would
suggest we do put some conditions on it
to say obviously a Shetland pony only
the question I wanted to ask was we're
talking about the the tech room the
stable block etc are you saying that if
it was smaller then it would be
acceptable you have more room on the
site itself for the Shetland pony or are
you saying because it's that size you
can't do that as what's one question
no the issue is not the size of the
stable the issue is that we need some
kind of spatial gauge in order to
maintain openness in the Greenbelt to
keep the land largely free of
development sometimes you need to give
way by accepting an actual built form of
development and in this case this is
equivalent to one stable that's fine but
the standard for for care which we like
highjacked to to give us that spatial
relationship that requires for one of
these stables this is where that they
say the feed and the tack room are but
the the animal being stabled is to
require 0.4 that is what 0.4 of a
hectare which is 1 acre or there abouts
now this site if we jump to the thank
you this this area I think in total
notwithstanding this here is about 1.7
of a hectare so it's less than half of
the point for half would be 0.2 of a
hectare so there is a substantial
difference in in the size that's
required so what we say is that because
you've got a responsibility as a council
to maintain openness but at the same
time grant planning permission where you
can for recreational uses and buildings
that are considered appropriate like
this there's a compromise or a balance
to be struck that you achieve it
effectively on a big enough site where
yes the care is all provided but in this
case we're saying that it would be a
small site to have one stable on in
planning terms there maybe background
issues we could get hung up on on feed
and care and and things like this but
you it's less so in planning that you're
looking at the care issues it's more of
the relationship between building to
size of sites if that helps chairman
yeah well she'll come back at the end I
really just crests or a little bit
information about the building itself I
take it the building itself doesn't have
any form of footings or anything like
that it's like I think sometimes
referred to as mobile buildings it could
be moved yeah
now it's chairman I'd imagine I mean
looking at the applicant it'd probably
have a raft on it it was like a slab
this is not to be confused with the
field shelters that do not require
planning permission because you can
attach them to a tractor or Land Rover
and time around and the the point in
planning law there is that they don't
have a fixing they come in on like skis
if you like that are built into the base
and because they can be moved like I
said you tie a vehicle to it and pull it
around technically it does not require
planning permission this is a planning
application quite rightly put before you
for a building that would have what we
call permanence it would be fixed to the
ground that the technique of the
foundation would be something for the
applicant I would suggest it be a
perhaps a slab but that the actual
foundation design isn't really an issue
before you that's roughly if planning is
not granted what be to stop the
applicant point horse in there and just
let your graze
chairman noting the grazing of a horse
where it is turned out into a field does
not require planning permission this
case law that the keeping of a horse
does and what the difference is is if
you go to that horse perhaps twice a day
feed and water it maybe riah dick groom
it etc it's held that's keeping a horse
requiring planning permission but if
more like agriculture you just turn the
animals out and a gun see and once every
few days leave them largely to their own
devices that is held not to require
planning permission Thank You chairman I
think I understand you how you
expressing the matter in relation to
proportionality with regards to the
green belt and the amount of land that's
there but I think I know that it's less
of an issue in relation to planning but
I think he's very important that we
should be seen to be making sure that
when we make decisions about welfare of
animals that we are looking to do that
in the most appropriate way now I've
heard that there is precedent for making
conditions about what type of animal can
be allowed on-site but these there's
always the
the problem of enforcement if someone
decides at some time later on down the
line if they want to put horse on their
Willie it would be completely
inappropriate so I would be reluctant to
even go down condition in it to a
Shetland pony if it's if it's is so
undersized that it would perhaps be a
welfare issue for anything that might be
on the in future I think endorse what
what you said there I think if there
were a condition relating to a type of
animal first of all you've got the
discussion which could be quite
complicated about what the type of
animal is what the breed is the relative
size within the breeds you've got the
monitoring of that which clearly isn't
something the council would undertake
and then the reality of dealing with an
enforcement and I just can't see that
being a sensible use of the the
council's priorities I think that if it
were a welfare issue there are other
authorities better suited than ourselves
to do to deal with that so yeah severe
depending on which way this goes I don't
think condition to a target of an animal
would actually be appropriate there
that's the Western do you want to come
back and carry on yes thank you I was
gonna I was going to ask about the
buildings anyway I think also we're
talking about the size of the animal not
SC the breed I still feel that we could
we could put some type of condition on
on that if we were a mind to approve
this this evening as I said I think the
gentleman who spoke was spoke very very
well on this I really haven't got
anything else to say I'd like to for
where approve this planning if possible
will if I had a seconder and then take
it from there please chairman okay so in
terms of conditions that would go with
this approval if we move to a vote
yeah please
chairman you would need the time limit
which would require you to stipulate
that the planning permission is
implemented within three years and
you'll also say that the County
archaeologist has requested that there's
there's archaeological interest
generally in the area and any any
digging around as it were where those
works he would like the opportunity to
survive those so an archeological
examine laughing in the term he's
actually used but it wouldn't require
him to dig up the whole site because
that's going to be undisturbed it would
only be these areas up here where a base
will be put down and potential
archaeological remains might be
disturbed in that process those are the
two that I would recommend chairman for
the sake of clarity we need to have a
reason attached as well so the the
motion that you're putting forward
chairman thie time limit is a statutory
time late in the Planning Act and the
archaeologist has given us reason for
that condition in his in his
recommendation of course there is
another reason that I'm having usefully
reminded of that where you are
potentially overturning the advice
that's given to you you have to give a
reason for that so that's not the same
as the reasons to the planning
conditions it is where you have perhaps
weighed up considered the merits of the
application and come to a different view
we would need a reason for that outcome
if that helps German
councillor Weston the other thing you
you've mentioned but mr. castle hook
where myself have also mentioned was
about the horse do you want to pursue
that one yeah I think that one as well
sir chairman also there the structure be
definitely be wooden structure no
nothing concrete or I think that would
be another stipulation on on the the
fear playing as well and again I just
say one one say horse one what - one
animal only one small horse pony
Shetland pony whatever well we need to
be clear a mentioning size of animal or
number of animals
I say well number of number okay and the
number being one okay
mumbles
impossible impossibility science eyes
are always in their differences so just
one one moment we just
[Music]
right Casa Westin so you put forward a
motion for approval officers have
outlined some conditions they feel
appropriate you've stated one one animal
on the site one horse on the site the
horse Pony counts a step to a second did
you is there any any members got any
lack of clarity about sorry chairman and
also the structure being structure being
invaded meaning of tender can Tim vote
sorry yes rock chairman okay if I could
help there the actual application
details are for I wouldn structure it
might help them is rather than specified
wooden is if we have the standard
condition we use to list the building to
be approved in accordance with the
approved plans which show timber
constructions and also like the first
item you sort and I allows the applicant
to come back and make any minor changes
through that facility should they wish
to do so should they decide the doors
need to be in a slightly different place
or something okay that's fine and also
you said about yours you well I don't
think that the conditions me air air
concerns may be unmanned I'm talking
about what we both spoke about so we're
still talking about one animal which
could be a Shetland pony or it could be
a car horse
how's the stepped out can I suggest that
we do it by the measurement of the pony
I'm not sure what the size of a second
Tony is but I can tell you something
like an X more pony which is a lot
bigger is something around about eight
to ten hands I do fear we're getting
into areas that members will have
challenges in visualizing understanding
and making a informed decision on that's
my concern chimp chairman Tom Foster
I do believe that a pony and any riders
in the room may correct me is less than
14 hangs and it's been suggested eight
to ten but what if we get a Shetland out
there that happens to be eleven hands hi
this is this is the dilemma with precise
measurement and classification like any
living thing they come in all shapes and
sizes but we're probably officers would
be able to tell whether it's a Shetland
type of of pony by I but only members
hands I mean officers are comfortable if
if members are like that the issue for
us and again maybe members of thinking
more of the welfare rather than the the
issue for planning spatial planning the
issue professionally from officers is
the relationship of building to sight so
really whilst bus members are concerning
themselves with the welfare and it being
a Shetland he could if members were to
prove this tonight a Shetland could go
in there a horse could go in there and
have have perhaps less land from a
welfare point of view which is the chair
said is an issue for another
organization the issue for this
committee is the relationship between
the built form and the site area so if
you're finding the building acceptable
for a Shetland I think you ought to find
it acceptable for a full-blown horse so
you only I think really need to concern
yourself with the number of horses
rather than worry too much about how
much grass a bigger horse might need or
something like that that helps chairman
remembers I I think that that that's
very useful input there and I think it's
sufficient for us to make a decision on
so we have motion put forward and
seconded the conditions as we go
outlined which mention or because the
the gist of this is about the
relationship of the green belt so those
members in favor of the approval please
indicate those against that item is
approved and the reason for the decision
[Music]
[Laughter]
now you ask me a question and the reason
for the decision to to house a Shetland
pony small horse
reasons say just hurt try it trying to
help you out a little there that you
feel that the relationship between the
built form and the open space in this
specific location with this specific use
is not going to compromise our policy
yeah yes chairman yes chairman thank you
okay the decisions made but thank you
kind of on a point of order I would have
thought that the reasons should have
been provided to the committee before
the vote otherwise if if the reason
wasn't appropriate maybe it might have
affected the decision if you wish to
challenge that at a later stage it's
your prerogative okay thank you very
much members meeting closed